i never have i've only played it once or
twice
when it first came out and i never came
back to it again so
i'm gonna play this and then every time
i die i'm gonna i'm gonna get out and
i'm gonna check
to see if i'm higher or lower in the
queue because right now i'm
at three still but that's fine because
i'm getting the content
you know what i mean i'm getting the
sweet delicious content
so easy i have done a video on geometry
dash wait i did it in the makeup
challenge
that's right didn't i oh i'm so
pretty i did i did do it okay so we're
gonna blast through this level because
i'm really good at this game
oh yeah there we go i'm number two
hey i'm number two i did it i'm number
[ __ ] [ __ ]
guys two yay all right
okay we're doing good we're doing good
guys okay so i'm gonna load back up into
the game and i'll check back in just a
second
let's get the hard stuff in here no it's
locked is it locked
huh finger dash
oh god oh god oh god
how would you do that what
what what what
what what wait
wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute don't oof me
how oh
but i can't i can't beat it
i can't possibly be in it don't you move
me
oh what did i do i oh
hold to dash what oh
learning mechanics that i probably
should have learned in all the other
levels leading up to this one
wow it all makes
we begin
[Music]
oh what place am i ah [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass let's go back into it
pum again him we began
[Music]
[Laughter]
i just picked going crazy from waiting
for going crazy
in another way ah frick bomb
begins becca we be friends
oh god three god it's only
game why you have to be mad i
am not mad i'm not
not definitely not
here we go
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[Music]
pump against oh [ __ ]
oh boy oh
hey i made it farther pump
maybe it's french bam
baguettes eiffel tower ham
baguettes we only do fromage
[Music]
but i get that on the first try and then
i can never get it ever again
oh really oh okay two
we're number two which means it'll just
be another two hours
it's okay i got this all right we're
close
just like we're close to getting through
this level maybe it's portuguese
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh god i thought i had that i'm trying
to sight read and it's not working
but i can do it if you just let me
concentrate if i concentrate my
chi i'm gonna get it everything else is
just easy this
child's play oh yeah easy easy easy as
could be
easy easy easy
oh i missed it
why did i not get it what
oh i didn't jump there pam baguettes
oh oh
don't oof me oh what place am i
two all right i'm still two which is
good to know uh [ __ ] oh well
i'm not mad i'm glad i'm happy i'm
having a great hip happening time
did i oh i didn't make it wait
wait i'm confused oh i'm upside down i
gotta jump oh
that's what it is oh i'm just dumb well
much like the answer to all my
life's problems the answer is i'm dumb
is this too loud
by the way i never asked is this too
loud is it too loud
it might be a bit too loud i'm gonna
turn it down just just a smell just a
smell
no well i turned it down anyway so
whatever it's down now
oh now it's too quiet oh so sad oh
life's hard for
a viewer you never think about how we
streamers
have it how tough we have it with our
with our big
paychecks and and our big mansions that
we all live in
do you know how how we have to live huh
it's hard it's hard
it's it's hard we have to endure this
man
it's hard you guys ever have pity on us
no i don't think you ever do
you never ever understand ow oh yeah i
ever understand
driving all our teslas mark 2702s
i can't believe you would ever just not
not appreciate
what we go through every day playing
video games oh you think it's so easy
huh
well i mean apparently not according to
what i'm doing
but yeah whatever i
oh [ __ ] i shouldn't jump there it's all
it is
yeah thanks for the priest thanks at
least someone preaches
thanks for the priest with the five
dollars attached to it
i swear i'm not really an [ __ ] guys i
swear it's just it's all an act it's an
act is this an act i don't oh really i'm
not really an [ __ ]
i just you know sometimes you know where
am i
two okay i'm number two still it's good
oh good [ __ ]
i do i know i do i know both of the game
and both at life
by the way they brought back the
referral program
they brought back the referral program
for tesla's
mark 2702 is back in business baby
i'm gonna actually like concentrate so i
can
not mess up
oh god i jumped oh god my twitchy finger
my my i don't like that mark two seven
everybody knows it everybody loves it
everybody loves knows mark 2702 it is
the premiere code use it ever every
checkout possible and you'll find
magical discounts and eventually a free
tesla will show up at your door
god damn it why am i doing this i'm just
trying to kill time but i'm building up
stress that i'm gonna take out on the
unfortunate people of no pixel
city los santos now that i'm hearing it
i do hear [ __ ] baguettes
so i think it's french [ __ ] baguettes
maybe this we
can alright we're translating this
slowly and but surely
listen to it
[Music]
it's [ __ ] baguettes maybe this wee
eekend it's really it's really
contemplative piece the lyrics are
beautiful [ __ ]
baguettes maybe the sweet oh come on
hashtag [ __ ] packet not everything needs
a hashtag but you know in this case
i think you're absolutely right it
absolutely does need a hashtag
oh come on i jumped everybody heard it
in my clacky-ass keyboard that i hate
[ __ ] baguettes maybe this week fair is
not fair when it comes to this game the
game is not fair therefore it's not fair
to say that this game is fair
it's not fair
i jumped
that was me that was me being a dummy it
was me being a dummy
it was me being a dummy that was me was
just some dumb in my brain and i was
dumb
i don't know why i did that that was
dumb that was dumb with me man my brain
just dumb my fingers too dumb
everything pardoned me too dumb to even
contemplate doing anything about this
god damn it i thought it was either too
early or too late
too early or too late because i
overcompensated the last time that i
didn't jump with an early jump and now
i'm just stuck in purgatory because i'm
too stupid to even contemplate doing it
right
no don't jump on the third one ah man my
finger just like twitched hey twitch
twitch.tv you ever heard of twitch prime
man what a competent segue listen if you
haven't heard of twitch prime it's this
lovely lovely service that allows you
for free to subscribe to your favorite
twitch streamer it is just the best
use code mark 2702 to double your
free twitch prime subscription today
[Music]
oh god why my brain just like farted out
because i thought i died
on the other thing because i was too
high and then i was like for some reason
i just went into a limp noodle
like kind of sensibility and i just fell
over and died
oh god i'm so sick of this song i'm so
sick of [ __ ] baguettes
i can't if i have to look at another
[ __ ] baguette
it'll be the end of me oh my god oh my
god what is wrong with me
what is wrong with that
oh why did i let go why would i let go
why why did i let go
[Music]
new terror
was that a troll was that tricky was
that tricky dicky was that some tricky
dicky [ __ ]
huh huh i agree
not me indeed no i can't do practice
mode that's practically cheating oh what
place am i in
what
[ __ ] i will i will sit here all
goddamn day
i have other things that i was supposed
to do today but i will clear my [ __ ]
schedule
to get in this goddamn server i'm gonna
farm all the sweet
content that i need to get to get
here i will be here all [ __ ] day
so long as it gets me where i need to be
which is in this
goddamn server i've been watching people
play this for two
[ __ ] weeks and i haven't been able to
get in the server
because of one [ __ ] thing or another
but i am not gonna be thwarted
by this inane oh i didn't jump there
not this inane [ __ ] but that inane
[ __ ]
i this is the this is the this is the
the the the the the sacrimoni what is it
called the
the the testament of the testament of
chet
brunsworth i don't know whoever whatever
character i play
today in there this is this is his
cacophony what is the word i can't
remember the
the not the testimony does the the
trials and tribulation but that's not it
what's the word what's the word there's
a word for it with the the the the
the the testicles no not that so uh the
not the manifest destiny that's not the
word
not the [ __ ] baguettes no it's uh the
it's like it's like a bibliography but
not it's it's like this is the something
that
it's it's a word to describe like his
story
what's the word i can't i can't look at
chat at the moment i'm a little busy but
what's
there's a word for it the the ah what's
it what's the word
i can't think right now my brain is
dedicated to this ah what's the word
what's up with journey there's the
eulogy no biography memoir tribulation
testimony tribulation is it testament no
uh
no no it's like biography no it's not
it's not biography no
god that's not it no autobiography it's
not
autobiography i think it's testament
this is the testament of
chet chet penis worth the
upbringing the manifesto the the
prophecy the geography the
the trione oh there's an isn't there
another word for it or is it testament
what is it the revelation the the the
odyssey
that's close odyssey is close it might
be testament but
that doesn't feel right chronicle yes
that's it
this is the chronicle of chet dixworth
chronicle this is the chronic that's the
word that's the word i was looking for
testament to cl they're all synonyms but
chronicle
these are the chronicles of chet
dixworth
and chet dixworth is number two in this
goddamn line
all right anyway let me concentrate on
this
[Music]
ah oh come on oh you
you come on i'm gonna get in this i just
gotta remember that this is not the end
of my day
i don't suck
what what i didn't even see what
happened it happened so fast i didn't
even notice what was going on
ah what the [ __ ] did i do i somehow
recovered that
i don't know how oh my god i mean i died
but i mean i recovered the mistake that
i made before
which was letting go of the space bar so
that's good you guys
it didn't look like i did anything good
but trust me something good came out of
that
what but i hit it but i hit it
but but but i hit it i hate my life
i hate i hate my life hate hate my life
hate my sweet life
oh [ __ ]
no don't ah frick knock
oh [ __ ] girl let's do it again
let's go again come on oh i don't have
much time
maybe or maybe i'm maybe i'm never
getting in or maybe this is just another
lie
i wouldn't be surprised if it was
another lie you know just another lie
in the history of lies the long history
of lies
there comes in my life
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] we in it we're getting
in
[Music]
you